hello everyone welcome to the Laing
focused Channel and my name is Paul
today this is just a quick video to talk
about an interesting linguistic
phenomenon something that might come up
in some of my videos in the future and
that is the topic of language isolates
often when I talk about languages I talk
about the family that language belongs
to and how it's related to other
languages in that family
for example Hebrew and Arabic are sister
languages of the Semitic language family
French and Italian are sister languages
of the Romance language family but did
you know that there are some languages
that have no family whatsoever those are
called language isolates a language
isolate as far as we know has no genetic
relationship with any other language
that means that it does not descend from
the same ancestor language as any other
language that we know of they are
basically a language family with only
one member some commonly known language
isolates are the Basque language which
is spoken in parts of France and Spain
also the Ainu language which is spoken
in Hokkaido and northern Japan some
people say Korean although that one is
disputed and also some Native American
languages as well as some languages on
the island of New Guinea New Guinea
happens to be the most linguistically
diverse place on the planet if you want
to know more about it check out this
video right here why are their language
isolates well one possible reason is
that that language used to belong to a
family that had numerous languages in it
but that one particular language became
dominant and replaced all of the others
or maybe all the other languages in that
family were replaced by a different
language for example a language of a
conquering army but one particular group
refused to give up and their language
became a language isolate it is possible
for a new language isolate to arise if
that community of people is completely
separated completely isolated from other
languages
that's because children have the ability
to spontaneously create new language in
these modern times that happens most
often with sign languages there have
been numerous cases around the world of
children in deaf schools spontaneously
creating new sign languages that are
completely unrelated to any others in
the world some linguists say that if you
took a group of infants and you raised
them in an environment with no language
that they would spontaneously create the
own language isolate this is just a
quick video to introduce that linguistic
concept that some people have been
talking about in response to some of my
videos in particular the one about
Japanese and Korean if you have any
comments about this topic leave them
down below but stay tuned for another
feature video coming soon thank you for
watching have a nice day